what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob I think
I'm gonna go to the Ultra Music Festival
II I probably do you like Miami Music
week in March of 2019 and then I'm
buying tickets for the Olympics in 2020
and Tokyo Japan
I am excited for that we do in this baby
anyway we are covering heroes in crisis
DC's heroes in crisis event so this is
it's really like a highly anticipated
event here's one of the things to bear
in mind guys those guys who were new to
DC Comics whenever a story with the word
crisis gets thrown out of their people
initiative like basically you'd think
that it's gonna be like a cosmic event
because historically speaking that's
always been the case like when it comes
to these major cosmic events I really
started with crisis on Infinite Earths
zero-hour crisis and time then it became
Infinite Crisis then Final Crisis but
you also had identity crisis in there
which was the first time that you had an
event like that that wasn't cosmic in
scope which reads to saying it didn't
impact the entire universe like it
wasn't being destroyed or something
along those lines and this is another
one this heroes in crisis doesn't deal
with like the the end of the world it
actually deals with like how superheroes
function and what they do when they're
basically suffering from PTSD and this
is cool
because what this does is it initially
picks up with Booster Gold and there's
really no better care to depict then
like somebody like him that's dealing
with you know essentially like crisis
level events because we know from the
most recent story for example in
Detective Comics that Booster Gold had
the idea to like save Batman it
basically like give him like the gift
that Booster wanted to give Batman was
like the perfect life and so he went
back in time and saved his parish from
being killed and that caused all kinds
of problems because then it turned out
that like you know his parents ended up
being killed anyway and so it's kind of
crazy when it comes to Bruce Wayne's
whole idea and Booster Gold trying to do
the right thing and and so on and so
forth and so what this does is it
initially switches over to Harley Quinn
now these are a series of interviews
that DC kind of throws in there for the
purpose of establishing what sanctuary
is now we know by definition from the
various stories that we've seen that
sanctuary is where the heroes go when
they're dealing with a crisis of sorts
when the the overwhelming aspect of
being a hero becomes too much for them
to bear sanctuary is where they're
supposed to go to but it's largely been
ambiguous up to this point we didn't
really know what sanctuary was about we
didn't know if it was spearheaded by
some doctor somewhere we don't really we
didn't really know if it was just an
organization where superheros just sit
down and talk to other superheroes and
that's it there is no exterior source
out there there's no doctors or you know
no medicine or anything like that we
didn't really know how that worked and
so Harley Quinn's interview here I guess
heard talking point really just kind of
comes with the nature of her character
in saying that like she
familiar with trauma because she used to
be like a psychologist or somebody that
worked with individuals minds but as she
began to go crazy by virtue of the Joker
she's kind of sorted to switch to this
idea of somebody saying like like create
like these people out there with all
these problems like we should just like
smash them with a sledgehammer which is
just like get rid of them which is kind
of an extreme and extreme point but she
also kind of has a breakdown towards the
end and that's the cool thing about this
because you see this sort of systematic
adjustment to her character the first
she starts off confident then she starts
to use comedy as like as a defense
mechanism and then she starts to get to
like the inner part of herself and then
she starts to cry and so it's really one
of these like one of these moments where
she sort of it's like it her character
being broken down as one of these things
were like all she needed to do was just
talk and so what this does is it jumps
back over to Booster Gold and it's kind
of funny because in this initial segment
there was this you know this diner woman
who was like hey there's another hero
here and boo she's like that's not a
hero that's a villain that's like well
is it gonna be a fight and he's like yes
it's gonna be a fight and it's kind of a
cool thing because the way this unfolds
that the way that that like Tom Kean
does this is so cool it's like a fight
that's building two anticipation because
you're talking about like Harley Quinn
showing up here on the scene and then
it's just kind of like it's only a
matter of time before they fight nobody
else really seems to know and even
booster booster gold's aware this is
gonna turn into a fight Harley Quinn's
like yeah this is gonna turn into a
fight and so it's really just kind of
like when do we strike it's one of those
classic sort of like like you know
Mexican standoff scenes you know for
example from like you know the good the
bad the ugly at the end the Mexican
standoff scene that lasted like 10
minutes before anybody started shooting
anybody else it was kind of weird but at
this point we switch over to Superman
and we kind of get Superman just sort of
arriving on the scene for a particular
location now again the invocation of
Superman in this story means that it
that we're not dealing with like small
beans here that we're dealing with a
pretty significant event and so from
here we jump over to a guy named blue
jay
now blue jay was a character who was
originally introduced back in 1971 in
Justice League of America issue number
87 I'm pretty sure and he was created by
Michael Friedrich now with regards to to
his character he's kind of like
ant-man in the sense that like he can
shrink down the difference is that he
grows wings when he shrinks but the
funny thing about this is that he really
just kind of says like like I can
control my power under normal
circumstances I'm very good at it but as
time has progressed I seem to have lost
control of my power and so it's one of
these things where it sort of feels like
he has like a mental block in place now
blue jay is a pretty small-time guy
means he's not a big superhero which is
probably why you've never heard
these small fish but the cool thing
about this is this kind of cutting you
know tom kean telling us that the
struggle of being a superhero isn't
relegated to just the big guys right
it's not like you know the struggle of
being Superman the struggle to being
Batman or Wonder Woman or Aquaman or
something like that it affects everybody
in some former fashion big and small
which is actually a pretty cool idea
it's very akin to like Civil War from
Marvel Comics those you guys who read
that where you basically had like like
everybody from the top at big guys
Captain America Iron Man so on all the
way down to the bottom with like Heroes
for Hire who were basically experiencing
this rift in the superhero community so
it's kind of a cool concept but from
here of course the fight breaks out
between Harley Quinn and Booster Gold
and it goes exactly as you would expect
it to I mean for the most part Buescher
is able to hold his own but Harley
Quinn's driven by absolute insanity and
madness and so when she starts lashing
out it's just kinda like look she's not
gonna stop here I mean she's just sort
of lost her mind in the moment and so
what we end up doing is switching over
to a Batman to Superman and to Wonder
Woman now this is basically the Trinity
that we're dealing with here and that
really seems to be what this story is
boiling down to in a lot of ways can we
also just say here this is an amazing
drawing clay man's the one who's drawing
who's doing like the art for the comic
and it looks emerging like I would want
this framed without the speech bubbles
like just the just the picture and no
speech bubbles do that would love that
like that would be that like have that
and frame it my house it would be on
there anyway with the Trinity of DC
comics it's one of the important things
when you're talking about what's
basically a whodunit murder mystery the
Trinity is oftentimes invoke didn't
invoked more than anybody else and the
reason we call them the Trinity is
because they're kind of like the the if
there was such a thing the one-two-three
punch of DC Comics really the comic book
industry Batman of course is the
original antihero Superman's the
original superhero and Wonder Woman is
the original like you know female
empowered superhero and so you take all
three of these things and it's like
these are the three that the top three
heroes that DC has but them arriving is
sanctuary is predicated on the idea that
someone's been going around and killing
superheroes but you basically end up
having like this this field full of
bodies you've got you've got like you
know some of whom are our small-time
guys some of whom are pretty big guys
but they've all basically been killed
off and so what we end up doing is
having Superman enter into this house
only for us to find the two biggest
players in the DC Universe so far who
have been killed off Arsenal red arrow
and while in the red haired Wally West
and this is actually pretty big because
the question is who the hell killed them
like is it you know doing this is is
it's kind of crazy the way Tom King does
this because of you could take it a
couple different ways the fact that is
just kind of like wall-e and Arsenal or
confirmed dead like you would think it
would be like a big dramatic moment when
like you end up finding out they're dead
but it's just kind of like yep they're
dead alongside everybody else is kind of
the feeling that you get but what this
also seems to point out is that this is
indicative of a much bigger picture
there's something far more significant
going on here the death of these
characters alongside all these other you
know essentially small-time superheroes
is really designed to say that their
deaths are a byproduct of somebody out
there being vengeful or what-have-you
but they're all superheroes that at the
end of the day Wally West's arsenal
don't are are really no different from
all the other heroes who were out there
regardless of how small they are they
all fight crime they all try to be the
bad guys and they all struggle with
being a superhero in their own way that
they all have their own their own
desires their own motivations all the
things that they regret and they suffer
from and so that's kind of the crazy
scenario is because what we're basically
told here is that sanctuary was set up
by like Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
as a place for superheroes to deal with
like the process of struggling to deal
with what it means to be a hero to deal
with like the emotional toll that it
takes which is pretty cool because
that's something you never really see in
DC comics or really in comic books as a
whole and in reality that's just a
holdover from the Silver Age this is the
holdover from like 1950s comic books
they're back then back in the day you
had superheroes who fought the bad guys
and the superheroes beat the bad guys
and then the day was done and that was
it and you might see some emotional
struggle in their comics with regards to
like the loss of something for example
1971 Peter Parker loses Gwen Stacy 1972
I think it was eobard thawne killed iris
West
and so Oh Barry Allen went you know went
out and killed eobard thawne I mean you
have like these moments where it kind of
impacts the characters but no one's ever
really dealt with the idea of like when
the hero saves the day who saves the
hero that's that's the question that
none of the comic book companies ever
really dealt with before and so it's
really really cool to see this happen
and so it's almost kind of crushing
because it almost seems as though that
the entire basis behind sanctuary is
sort of all for naught that these people
were all brought here to find a place of
Solace to find a place of comfort to
find a place of healing and instead they
found death and so as it's it's pretty
sad to see and so switching over to to
Harley and Booster Gold you know it's
one of these things where they sort of
have this conversation back and forth
and Booster Gold starts making allusions
to the idea and then actually makes kind
of an outright statement that Harley
Quinn was the one who killed everyone
and that's what's so crushing is is this
like you went there and you killed every
single person and Harley
when says no no I didn't kill anybody
I'm not the one who's responsible for
everyone dying here the person who's
responsible for that booster is you and
so basically we get this kind of
transition to Booster Gold himself where
he's doing his interview and he's saying
like I know exactly what you guys are
about which makes sense because he's
from the future but he's like I know
exactly what you guys are about I know
exactly what you guys do you guys are an
organization that essentially like the
the overseers the ones that help the
superheroes get through their crises or
essentially robots built on Kryptonian
tech that are a combination of Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman's personalities
and so Booster Gold Sibley says yeah
like I'm here to start talking like I'm
here for help and so it leaves things
very very ambiguous because we don't
really know what what involvement
Booster Gold had here we don't really
know if he outright killed everyone if
he set in motion a set of events that
led to all their deaths
if it's a some villain that Booster Gold
set off by virtue of being there and
talking to them or something like that
we don't really know and that's one of
the cool things here is there so many
possibilities it's entirely possible
that this organization sanctuary will
eventually go awry there will basically
see what amounts to like a small time
futures in where you end up having like
these Kryptonian robots that take over
the bodies of the superheroes and try to
destroy the world there's any number of
things that that could play out in this
scenario so it's pretty interesting and
it's actually pretty cool and it works
pretty well because of course it creates
a lot of anticipation for the next issue
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you